[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen bevor es jetzt richtig
losgeht gleich müssen wir euch warnen in
unserer heutigen Geschichte geht es
unter anderem um Kindesmissbrauch und
Suizid also wenn euch das zu nahe geht
dann hört diese Folge bitte nicht
alleine an oder überhaupt gar nicht und
die ganze Geschichte wäre auch nur sehr
schwer zu ertragen wenn sie nicht Gott
sei Dank ein Happy End hätte ja aber
dieser Weg zum Happy End ist verdammt
hart und für mindestens zehn Frauen
kommt es zu spät damit würde ich sagen
Mirko liegt direkt los
3 november 1984 Tampa Bay Florida 2 Uhr
morgens eine warme Nacht eine leere
Straße eine junge Frau auf einem Fahrrad
lisa mcway ist auf dem Heimweg von ihrem
Job in einem donutladen die Hälfte des
Weges hat sie hinter sich aber je näher
sie ihrem Ziel kommt desto schwerer
fällt jeder Meter jeder treten die
Pedale sie hat heute extra eine
Doppelschicht gearbeitet um die
Heimfahrt hinauszuzögern doch es gibt
kein zurück mehr lisa hat ihre
Entscheidung getroffen und so
schrecklich sie auch ist es ist ihre
Entscheidung eine der wenigen die sie in
den 17 Jahren ihres Lebens treffen
konnte es ist der einzige Ausweg den sie
sieht und sie wird ihn endlich gehen
heute Nacht im Haus ihrer Großmutter
wird sich Lisa das Leben nehmen
doch Lisa kommt nicht nach Hause
aus dem Nichts greifen sie zwei Hände
reißen sie vom Fahrrad dieser schreit
doch da ist er auch schon über ihr und
hält den Lauf einer Waffe an ihre linke
Schläfe halt den Mund sonst blase ich
dir das Gehirn raus
die Stimme eines Mannes Lisa wollte
sterben jetzt soll sie sterben glauben
sie aber es ist nicht mehr ihre
Entscheidung wieder will jemand anderes
über sie verfügen doch Lisa spielt nicht
mehr mit
[Musik]
und damit herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Mirko Kasimir und
ich bin Toni Heyer und die Geschichte
die wir euch heute erzählen da kann ich
mit Sicherheit sagen dass es eine der
bewegendsten und außergewöhnlichsten die
wir hier bisher jemals hatten absolut
und wie ihr wisst hatten wir hier schon
sehr sehr viele Fälle jeder auf seine
Art einzigartig oder auf seine ganz
eigene Art schrecklich und doch sticht
dieser Fall heraus wir erzählen euch
heute die Geschichte der Entführung von
Lisa mcway und diese Geschichte beginnt
lange vor diesem dritten november 1984
Lisas Mutter ist Alkohol und
drogenabhängig Lisa wird obdachlos und
lebt in den folgenden Jahren bei
verschiedenen Pflegefamilien als sie 14
ist holt ihre Großmutter sie zu sich was
nach Liebe Hoffnung und einem zu Hause
klingt das wird zu einem unfassbaren
Albtraum
der Freund ihrer Großmutter missbraucht
Lisa immer wieder auf äußerst brutale
Art manchmal hält er ihr eine Waffe an
die Schläfe während er sie vergewaltigt
die Großmutter weiß nicht nur von den
Vergewaltigungen sie bringt Lisa das
erste Mal zu diesem Mann und sagt ihr er
würde ihr beibringen wie man einen Mann
glücklich macht ein Zuhause wird zur
Hölle ich meine diese Vorstellung dass
die eigenen Eltern oder wie bei Lisa
Großmutter ihre Kinder und Enkel so
missbrauchen manchmal über Jahre hinweg
das ist unfassbar schrecklich und man
kann sich das auch nur ganz ganz schwer
vorstellen dabei geschieht das viel
häufiger als ein Angriff aus dem Nichts
ja die größte Gefahr geht dabei von
Vertrauenspersonen aus also von denen
die sozusagen legal Macht über die
Kinder und Jugendlichen haben aber man
muss natürlich festhalten dass die
meisten Vertrauenspersonen also ob jetzt
in der Familie in der Schule im
Sportverein und auch in der Kirche
Gemeinde
die sind natürlich vertrauenswürdig und
liebevoll ja auf jeden Fall es gibt halt
nur so viele von ihnen und darunter
einige wenige die dieses Vertrauen auf
die schrecklichste Atmos braucht und
dann eben an genau der Stelle sind wo
sie die Gelegenheit dazu haben Mirko es
taucht bei solchen Geschichten immer
wieder eine Frage auf warum ist sie
nicht einfach weggegangen warum hat sie
ihre Oma und deren Freund nicht
angezeigt warum hat sie das erduldet ja
du hast Recht auf den ersten Blick
scheint es vielleicht ein bisschen
seltsam denn sie war ja nicht im Keller
angekettet oder dergleichen sie ging zur
Schule hatte ihren Job im donutladen und
kehrte jeden Tag in das Horrorhaus
zurück aber man unterschätzt natürlich
völlig die psychische Gewalt die solche
Täter ausüben durch Drogen oder indem
sie das Selbstbewusstsein ihrer Opfer
völlig untergraben ihnen einreden sie
hätten nichts Besseres verdient indem
sie Scham als Wasser einsetzen so nach
dem Motto wenn du das erzählst dann wird
man dich auslachen und als [__]
beschimpfen so was in der Art und dann
ist da meist ja auch noch die große
Angst das einem zum Beispiel nicht
geglaubt wird lisa hat anscheinend
mehrmals versucht mit anderen über den
Missbrauch zu reden wurde aber nicht
ernst genommen ja das spielt vielleicht
derselbe Impuls rein den wohl jeder von
uns kennt man will solche Geschichten
einfach nicht glauben man will nicht
dass es sowas gibt nach drei Jahren
voller Vergewaltigungen und psychischen
und physischen Missbrauchs sieht Lisa
nur noch einen Ausweg sie will sterben
als sie in der Nacht des dritten
november 1984 von der Arbeit nach Hause
fährt hat sie mit dem Leben bereits
abgeschlossen der Abschiedsbrief ist
geschrieben der Plan steht fest dies
sind die letzten Stunden ihres Lebens
und dann in dieser dunkelsten Stunde an
diesen Punkt von dem es nicht tiefer
hinabgehen sollte da wird Lisa entführt
ein Fremder reißt sie vom Fahrrad hält
eine Waffe an die Schläfe legt ihr eine
Augenbinde um und zerrt sie in seinen
Wagen aber Lisa will nicht mehr sterben
nicht so nicht durch die Hand und durch
den Willen eines anderen sie wird alles
tun um dies zu überleben oder um sich
noch im Tod an ihrem Entführer und
Mörder zu rächen sie fehlt ihn an sie
nicht zu töten sie verspricht alles zu
tun was er von ihr verlangt und sie tut
was er von ihr verlangt als er ihr
befiehlt sich auszuziehen und ihn zu
befriedigen aber sie tut noch mehr hier
müssen wir noch etwas zu Lisa erzählen
sie ist Krimi und True Crime Fan gerade
gab es damals natürlich noch nicht in
der heutigen Form also als Podcast
sondern das waren fernsehsachen sowas
wie Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst in
Deutschland zum Beispiel
und sie hat dabei offensichtlich eine
Menge gelernt als ihr Entführer ihr die
Augenbinde anlegt spannt sie ihr Gesicht
an als sie die Muskeln wieder entspannt
lockert sich die Binde ein wenig und sie
hat einen schmalen Spalt unten durch den
sie etwas sehen kann nicht viel aber sie
wird sich jedes noch so kleine Detail
merken sie sieht dass das Auto weiße
Sitze hat sie erkennt das Wort Magnum
auf dem Armaturenbrett sie bemerkt einen
roten Teppich auf dem Boden des Wagens
und während der Fahrt hat sie eine Idee
die ich unglaublich genial finde es
gelingt ihr ihren Tampon herauszuziehen
und unter den Sitz fallen zu lassen ein
eindeutiges Beweisstück wenn sie es
lebend aus dieser Situation schafft wird
es ihre Geschichte bestätigen wenn nicht
wird es eines Tages helfen diesen Typen
zu überführen
der Entführer dessen Gesicht Lisa nicht
gesehen hat fährt mit ihr zu einem Haus
und führt sie hinein durch den kleinen
Spalt unter ihren Augen sieht sie einen
grünen Teppich mit gelben und roten
Flecken sie zählt jeden Schritt den sie
tun jede Treppenstufe und merkt sich
alles 19 Stufen danach links danach nach
rechts das muss seine Wohnung sein
also so eine Geistesgegenwart in so
einer traumatischen Situation dass
wirklich unglaublich dass sie es schafft
bei klarem Verstand zu bleiben und nicht
nur vor Panik durchzudrehen das ist
wirklich sehr bewundernswert
es gibt eine Menge Spekulationen darüber
wie sie das angestellt hat bis hin zu
der Vermutung dass der jahrelang
gewalttätige Missbrauch sie irgendwie
auf so etwas vorbereitet hätte aber ich
glaube das nicht ich glaube nicht dass
irgendetwas jemanden auf so eine
Situation wirklich vorbereiten kann
niemand kann sagen wir in so einer
Situation dann wirklich reagieren würde
ja was ich an dieser Theorie besonders
unangenehm finde ist dass man
vermuten könnte dass man dem Verhalten
des Freundes der Großmutter damit
irgendetwas Positives abgewinnen könnte
und das ja das kann man natürlich
absolut nicht akzeptieren ja absolut
Trauma ist Trauma und das hat nie was
positives vielleicht sagen wir einfach
lisa ist stark und Lisa ist vor allem
klug ich glaube darüber müssen wir auch
gar nicht diskutieren sie selbst sagt
übrigens dass sie die in Führung als
Zeichen Gottes gesehen hat der sie damit
vor der Sünde des selbstm bewahren
wollte aber
ich weiß ja nicht ganz
in der Wohnung bringt der Lisa ins Bad
befiehlt ihr sich auszuziehen dann nimmt
er die Augenbinde ab und schiebt sie in
die Dusche sie soll die Augen
geschlossen halten und sich von ihm
abwenden und sie befolgt all seine
Befehle und dennoch kann sie durch die
fast geschlossenen Augenlider erkennen
dass er kurze braune Haare hat die
Tortur dauert 26 Stunden immer wieder
fällt der Täter über die junge Frau her
vergewaltigt und schlägt sie und
gleichzeitig gelingt es Lisa zwischen
ihnen eine Art Vertrauensverhältnis
aufzubauen der Mann beginnt von sich zu
erzählen von einer gescheiterten
Beziehung für die er sich nun an allen
Frauen rächen will
er beginnt sie auszufragen sie erzählt
ihm auf sein Bitten hin wilde und
erfundene Geschichten darüber was
angeblich im mädchenumkleideraum der
Highschool so vor sich geht das meiste
was wir euch bisher erzählt haben wissen
wir weil Lisa überlebt hat aber ihre
Rettung verlief überhaupt nicht
geradlinig wie ihr im zweiten Teil
erfahren werdet verschlug es sie von
einem Ort des Grauens wieder in den
nächsten und ihr steht auch noch eine
unfassbare Erkenntnis über ihren
Entführer bevor also schaltet morgen
wieder ein wir hören uns in der zweiten
Hälfte dieser wirklich faszinierenden
und unglaublichen Episode bis morgen
eure Toni und euer Merkur